what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so we are getting into we're
getting in a Batman killing a god I
don't know why I'm laughing about that
but funny enough Batman kills cagey
beasts again so here is here's a whole
idea and we'll explain a little bit more
about what that means here in a second
but initially what this does is this
picks up with cagey beasts basically
arriving in the US now this is a bit
ambiguous and the reason why is because
cagey beasts he's been around for a
while and in reality the last we saw was
that he died and we won't kind of we
could talk about that here we can talk
about that right now
so when all-star Batman kicked off in DC
rebirth that was kind of scott Snyder's
way of just sort of telling the Batman
stories he always wanted to tell outside
of the existing continuity of DC rebirth
and the stories would just kind of fit
in wherever they fit in that was really
kind of the idea behind it and of course
again you know the Scott Snyder could
get away with that because you know he
and in Greg Capullo kind of had this
landmark run on Batman I would say
probably the best Batman run and
something around 20 years and so when
you look at that you look at the whole
idea of cagey beast and the way this
played out was that it was it was really
kind of like a comic-book adaptation of
the most dangerous game and for those of
you guys who had never seen ever read
that story which I would highly suggest
you do it's one of the best stories ever
the most dangerous game was it was a
story about a guy who hunted people
getting fed up with hunting animals he
literally started hunting people because
people could hunt back but nonetheless
the way that cagey beast ended with
all-star Batman it was really just like
Batman pushing him off a cliff
essentially and then Batman being saved
by do Thomas and so we didn't really
know the fate of KGB's but what the
thing about his character with him
showing up it's literally just like
amassing arms and armament it's going to
a place ordering guns and then basically
like setting things up and organizing
things and the reason why is because
what's going on while KGB's is doing all
this is you've got Batman and you've got
Dick Grayson now the way this starts off
Tom King does this so well the way this
starts off it's nothing special
it's just Batman and Dick Grayson
fighting like zombie you know like
zombie mummies and it's kind of cool but
it's really more of like the repartee
between the two it's like the jokes and
the the giggles and all that kind of
stuff in this this is a very important
thing to keep in mind because we talked
about this before we talked about a lot
during injustice but we talked about
this before that Nightwing has and and
really continues to be this kind of
bright shining star in the DC landscape
he was always kind of like the one that
sort of kept everybody cheerful in the
worst of situations he's the one that
made everybody laugh and when you look
at this whole thing that's exactly what
it is he's cracking jokes with Batman
and it's kind of like all you ever do is
grunt so like let's let's reverse roles
were like you tailed
jokes and I grunt it's just these funny
little moments you know these these
little things like that and that mankind
of plays along but it's but the cool
thing about this is Bruce Wayne is just
like dark and brooding right he's just
like pissed off of the world as this
really is that's really his shtick he's
just angry and when you have that whole
that whole thing if you've been reading
Batman long enough you can tell by the
way that writers do things you can tell
when he's getting a chuckle out of
something even if he doesn't show it and
Dick Grayson has been around Batman long
enough to be able to tell those small
little nuances those small little things
and it works and so as these two guys
are you know they're going through and
doing their whole thing and and you know
they end up having like this this funny
little race it's kind of cool you have
this funny little race we're so we're
gonna shoot off our little a little
grappling hooks and then like the first
one there wins of course Batman wins
because it's Batman what would a story
be if Batman lost it nonetheless you
know when they're going through and
they're there they're kind of having
their there back and forth and they're
enjoy each other's company basically
like their two friends hanging out in
the middle of all this
KGB loads up a sniper rifle and kills
Dick Grayson and this is mean it's it's
big I mean Dick Grayson has suffered
through things like this before
but it's it's a pretty significant
moment for it for Bruce and here's the
reason why this is why this works so
well with Tom King if you look at the
story in isolation its oh man another
story were where Dick Grayson is you
know where he's might be dead and you
might be gone you know and it's kind of
easy to scoff off but if you look at Tom
Kings run the totality of his run for
what it is and then you look at like
James Damien's Detective Comics and you
kind of combine the two together what
you get is like the last straw
since DC rebirth started there's been
dark nights to metal because of Batman's
actions and meddling with time when he
was sitting to the past by Darkseid that
led to Barbados arising and like the
Dark multiverse coming into existence
Clayface was reformed and then he was
killed I mean you you've had all these
things happen Selina Kyle Caitlin was
gonna way it was gonna marry Batman and
then she left him at the altar the guy's
life has just been getting progressively
worse worse and worse and worse and
worse and then like dick Grayson's dead
now it's like a crushing think but cagey
beast
loads his stuff up and leaves that's the
nature of KGB's that's what makes him so
dangerous when it comes to him as a
character he debuted back in 1988 he was
made by jim Starlin and he appeared in
in like i think was a 10 issue series
and it was called the night of the beast
ultimately when he first debuted in DC
Comics he was brought in by the fact
that the Cold War was essentially
winding down and relations between the
United States and Russia were beginning
to cool off
it was setting the stage for the US and
for the USSR I guess what would become
Russia to basically begin to mending the
bridge and this led to a rogue general
basically activating KGB stand sitting
around for the purpose of killing like a
handful of important officials some
political some business or what-have-you
this led to Batman intervening but
because of the fact that KGB s-- was a
Russian national
had he been arrested and turned over to
the police he would have been basically
sent back to Russia because at the time
it wouldn't look good for the United
States to extend an olive branch and so
in response to this Batman basically
locked him in a Cell underground and
left him there and so the idea was that
Batman killed KGB's now ultimately he
ended up escaping and because of the
fact that Batman doesn't kill it was
just kind of like an offhand remark of
well I told Jim Gordon that he was okay
and I told Jim Gordon about him and they
they took him in that was that was the
end of that but the way it was a version
of the way originally ended basically
KGB's was left to die by Batman that's
literally the way it was designed to
play out now with regards to KGB's
proper one of the other things here is
he's got like cybernetic enhancements
little things that sort of in that that
make him more dangerous and more
prodigiously than your average assassin
he's skilled in a wide array of
different martial arts she's literally
designed to be a one-man army the other
problem with this though is that we
never really learned about KGB's
backstory all we knew is that he was a
product of the KGB itself and that's it
that's really all we had and so going
into this basically it brings into the
idea of his father you know we're like
hey GB starts banging on the door and
his father fires off a shot he opens the
door and then KGB is there and it's like
okay so we're gonna start learning more
about his past but the difference here I
guess that the big thing here is that
with Batman he's pulling out all the
stops and that's what happens from time
to time that's why this has done so well
because what Tom King is doing here is
drawing on the aftermath of death in the
family of those you guys who don't know
death and the family was the story where
Jason Todd basically died at the hands
of the Joker and in response to this
Batman lost it like he got as close as
he ever got to becoming the Punisher
basically he was beating people half to
death he was taking the extra step more
so than he needed and that led of course
to the introduction of Tim Drake Tim
Drake came along and he deduced the
identities of dick Granada Grayson and
and Bruce Wayne as being Robin and
Batman respectively
Tim Drake ultimately joined forces with
Bruce Wayne and he became the new Robin
but during that time period that interim
period before Tim gray
Drake became the new Robin and before he
was able to kind of reel Batman back in
he was brutal and that's exactly what's
happening here it's not nearly as long
as a stretch of time but it is pretty
brutal because he shows up at Tommy
Gunn's place and just
throws him through a window and that's
not normal Batman fashion I mean
throwing like a Batarang around his neck
and like reeling him back in he's
snapped but it makes sense though it's
Dick Grayson I mean he's he's fought and
bled alongside Batman for so long and so
where he just kind of like I mean
literally like Yanks him back in that's
when Batman gets information he needs
and we end up finding out it's Kate he
basically finds out is KGB's KGB's was
the one who took out Dick Grayson and
that's an important thing to realize
here because Batman realizes he's not
someone to trifle with now it gets a
little hairy here
what is it happening is he basically
ends up traveling to meet with bronze
Tiger now this is one thing to bear in
mind bronze tiger is pretty dangerous if
I'm being honest with you like he's
pretty dangerous like I'm pretty sure in
Red Hood in the outlaws number 20
back in 2013 when he appeared he was
basically established over the course of
that and like his various run-ins with
Batman as being equal to if not better
than Batman when it comes to martial
arts and he's actually defeated him a
few times
now of course bronze tiger is also a
protector of Gotham but he's also a
person who has some some pretty
significant dealings with it with the
criminal underworld and because he's
travelled around so much because he
seemed so much Batman asked the question
who trained KGB now when it comes to
this this question being asked here is a
little strange because again this kind
of goes into the whole idea of DC sort
of picking and choosing what they keep
from the Batman mythos before the events
of the new 52 and so where we would
largely assume the Batman knows about
KGB's he knows what he's about he knows
his history so on and so forth the
question is does he truly know that or
is he just kind of running around with
it and that really seems to be the case
that he basically doesn't really know
anything about KGB's I mean bronze
Tigers literally explaining to a bunch
of old-school you know old-school guys
trained KGB's on his martial art skills
and an assasination average does so on
and so forth is Batman learning about
him and so again we kind of have to
assume Batman doesn't know anything
about KGB's take it for what it's worth
but the important thing about this is
that Ron's tiger warns Batman and he
says look what you're going into here
facing off against the beast against
KGB's this is not a small thing you're
going to find a man who can kill you
who's one of the most dangerous people
in the world so if you want to go do
that that's fine just be aware you might
be going to your own funeral in the
process and so that's why this is big is
because it's basically this kind of
establishing fact that like KGB's could
kill Bruce Wayne it's basically
establishing the danger of facing off
against someone like the Beast now
picking up with the KGB's you know
proper and have him conversing with his
father you know when he shows up at his
dad's house
essentially talking to him the important
thing here is that it really kind of
establishes that like hey jeebies never
really had a chance in the first place
that his father was hard court
his father was brutal more so than that
KGB's is equally as tough his father
really like beat the crap out of him all
the time in an effort to kind of you
know toughen him up but KGB's himself
had taken all those lessons and made
himself a hardened person as well and so
what he'd done over the course of his
career over the course of KGB's career
anyone who knew who he was anyone who
spent any real measure of time with him
he killed him including his own family
he turned himself into a veritable ghost
his father is really the only person
left who knows who he is his trainers
the whole nine yards they were all
eliminated and so we're Bruce Wayne goes
through and figures out that like the
father of KGB's is the only one who
knows where he is and basically that's
most likely where beats would go at the
very least to try to take care of these
last bits of who it is that knows his
identity Queen um you're kind of
switching back and the Beast takes out
his dad and that's the brutal thing is
he's and mrs. something to bear in mind
here the way this is done the way it's
written the way it's drawn it's
emotionless he doesn't shed it's here he
doesn't cry he just fires off a shot
kills his dad takes a shot of alcohol
and that's the end of it now the other
half of this is that with him being so
prodigious in terms of his combat skills
his enhancements of so on he sniffs out
pretty fast that Batman's on his way and
this is probably one of the best parts
of any Batman story I've ever read Tom
King I swear to god man this guy this
guy's got a golden pin when it comes to
writing Batman because there's this
there's no this is like a scene from
they live all right there's no words
here there's no talking here it's just
straight
knuckle fighting Batman throws a
Batarang through the window and the two
of them just get into this knock-down
drag-out fight and in reality they're
fighting to kill they're not fighting to
wound they're fighting to kill and
that's not something that you normally
see with Batman as team as he is here in
terms of the fact that he's holding like
he's he's fighting clear-headed with
logic and reason he's not fighting
emotionally he's completely emotional
because the closest thing he had to a
son has just been killed how else would
he react and that's why he's fighting
with such vengeance that's why he's
freeze fighting with such wrath like
this guy is going to die but the crazy
thing about this KGB's gets the upper
hand and again that's designed to show
how dangerous he is KGB's gets the upper
hand on Bruce Wayne even with only
having like one actual viable arm and
the other one being a prosthetic he gets
the upper hand on Batman that's how
dangerous cagey beast is and so the way
this plays out is awesome because Batman
uses one
is one of his little grappling hooks
fires it off at KGB and basically breaks
his neck in the process now this is a
crazy thing because Batman could have
killed him but he doesn't he leaves him
there out in the cold just leaves him
there and that's what's so crazy about
this is like it's kind of a replay of
the original like night of the piece but
like it's out here in the middle of cold
in the middle of nowhere
now in reality this is more or less
Batman taking the stance of like I don't
kill and in his truth he's not really
killing KGB's he's letting nature do it
for him which is fudging the numbers but
it still works you know it's still it
still works but it's it's it's so cold
and it's so methodical under normal
circumstances we look at that man and
it's just kinda like yeah he's cold and
calculating a methodical but with this
it's not really I mean it is that part
of him but it's also just emotionless
this man's going to freeze to death in
the cold and I don't care he deserves
whatever he gets the closest hospital is
300 klicks that way it's it's insane
like it's it's it's way out there like
you're probably gonna die here you
probably gonna freeze to death because
when it comes to KGB's it's one of the
important things to kept with to bear in
mind when it comes to KGB's despite the
fact that he has these cybernetic
enhancements he's still largely human he
has to eat he has to sleep and he's
still left it like the rigors of cold
can still impact him and can still kill
him and so that's the crazy thing that
the big question Bruce asked here is you
are I may at the end of the day despite
how dangerous you are despite where
you're capable of you're still just a
henchman you're still just a killer for
hire someone hired you someone hired you
to take out Dick Grayson I'm gonna find
who that person is and when I do
woe betide them woe betide their poor
souls because maybe I'll kill him I have
no idea but that's what's so dangerous
is because it's anybody's guess what the
hell Batman's gonna do but with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end if you are new here to
come this explain make sure you guys are
the sub button to become part of the Rob
core if you guys enjoy this video make
sure you drop a like and yeah Tom King
does it again Jesus I will catch you all
later peace
[Music]
[Music]